[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره بعد مقتل اربعه
اسرائيليين واصابه اخرين في هجوم تبنته
حركه حماس في مستوطنه عيله جنوب نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه
من ريكا عاصمه ايسلندا هذه الصور حيث
يجتمع وزراء دفاع دول شمال اوروبا لتعزيز
التعاون الدفاعي وبحث الاوضاع في اوكرانيا
الى الخرطوم وهذه الصور التي تردنا
منهناك مع دخول الهدنه ساعاتها الاخيره
ورصد مناوشات في العاصمه السودانيه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد اقتحام غير مسبوق لجنين ورد لم يتاخر
قرب نابلس مقتل اربعه مستوطنين من اصل
سبعه عند مدخل مستوطنه عيله بالضفه وحماس
تتبنى العمليه اسرائيل تعلن مقتل المنفذين
وتقول انهما من نابلس وعشرات المستوطنين
يعتدون على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في حواره
حركه حماس تقول ان عمليه مستوطنه عيله رد
على اقتحام جنين ومخططات تقسيم الاقصى
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقر بغياب اي معلومات
استخباريه عن العمليه نتنياهو يجري
مشاورات امنيه ويقول ان جميع الخيارات
مفتوحه كثير يطالب بشن عمليه واسعه النطاق
في الضفه تشمل اغتيالات
هدنه الايام الثلاثه في السودان تقترب من
نهايتها اشتباكات متقطعه في مناطق
بالخرطوم
ونطاق المعارك يتسع في انحاء اقليم دارفور
وسقوط مزيدا من الضحايا ومبادره ايجاد
للحل تتحول الى ازمه مع اتهام الخرطوم
الاليه الرباعيه لتحدي السودان وانتهاك
سيادته
في اوكرانيا معارك محتدمه شرقا وجنوبا
وزير الدفاع الروسي يقول ان قوته تتصدى
لهجمات قوات نخبه اوكرانيه دربها الناتو
ويحذر من مغبه استهداف عمق الاراضي
الروسيه بصواريخ
تقول ان شبه جزيره القرم ارض اوكرانيا
وانها تدعم جهود استعادتها
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الدعوات المتزايده داخل
اسرائيل لشن عمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق
ردا على هجوم تبنته حماس قتل فيها اربعه
اسرائيليين عند مدخل مستوطنه عيد بالضفه
الغربيه وحديث نتنياهو بان كل الخيارات
صارت مفتوحه والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
كيف تقيمون ابعاد اي عمليه عسكريه تقدم
عليها اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه
جاءت النتائج على هذا النحو 20% قالوا
انها استرضاء للاطراف الحكوميه اما 35%
فراوا انها ستدفع المقاومه الى مواجهه
واسعه النطاق بينما 45%
قال وان عدم قدره ان لن تقدم نتائج امنيه
ولن تحقق هذه النتائج هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيه ودوليا
[موسيقى]
البدايه اذن من الاراضي الفلسطينيه فبعد
اقل من يوم عدد هجوم الاسرائيلي واقتحام
جنين اعلنت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مقتله اربعه مستوطنين وجرحى اربعه اخرين
في هجوم مسلح شنه فلسطينيا اليوم عند مدخل
مستوطنه عيله بين مدينتي رام الله ونابلس
بالضفه الغربيه الاذاعه الاسرائيليه قالت
ان منفذي من سكان بلده عريف بنابلس وان
احدهما قتل في موقع الهجوم والاخر قرب
طوباس
ربما لم يسمع احد بمستوطنه عيلي الصغيره
وسط الضفه الغربيه قبل اليوم لكنها تحولت
الى موقع حدث سيذكره المستوطنون جيدا بعد
الان على الطريق بين رام الله ونابلس يعيش
5000 اسرائيلي في المستوطنه المقامه على
اراضي قرن فلسطينيه شمال رام الله جنوب
نابلس يصل شاب فلسطيني ببندقيه واحده الى
مدخل المستوطن هناك ثمه محطه وقود يتراجع
الشاب ويطلق النار ليقتل اربعه مستوطنين
على الاقل ويصيب اربعه اخرين من المسافه
الصفر قبل ان يقتله مستوطن مسلح ككل
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه لكن من اين
جاء الشهيد وفق الروايات فان المنفذه جاء
من القرى الجنوبيه لمدينه نابلس وتحديدا
من قريه حواره على بعد 20 كيلومترا الى
الشمال من لا يعرف حواره تلك القريه التي
دعا وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الى محوها
بعد ساعات قليله من قيام مستوطنين بالفعل
بادرام النار في عشرات المنازل
كاتب القريه في سياقات المكان والزمان لا
تبدو الضفه الغربيه متاثره بالضربات
الاسرائيليه خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
تلك ضربات قتلت قرابه 170 فلسطينيا منذ
بدايه العام بينهم عشرات المسلحين ترتكز
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه شبه اليوميه على
منطقتين نابلس وجنين بشكل خاص مع تصاعد
ظاهره المقاومه المسلحه في المدينتين
عمليه علي جاءت بعد 24 ساعه فقط من ضربه
قويه تلقاها جيش الاحتلال في جنين من هناك
عجز احد اقوى جيوش المنطقه لساعات عن سحب
قواته والياته المعطبه بفعل عبوات محليه
الصنع على ذكر العبوات محليه الصنع تلفت
عمليه عدي النظر الى القدرات العسكريه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه الحديث عن
اسلحه خفيفه لا تتجاوز المسدسات وبنادق
الكلاشنكوف او الام 16 لا حديث عن صواريخ
مضاده للدروع او الطيران ولا الغام نوعيه
الاحاديث عن ملاجئ او خنادق او مناطق
حدوديه الحديث فقط عن قرار بالمقاومه ذلك
قرار يبدو انها استطاع تجاوز العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه المكثفه في الضفه
الغربيه كما استطاع تجاوز العقبات امام
الحصول على اسلحه تكفي لابقاء اسرائيل
متاهبه على الدوام
هذا وقالت حركه حماس في بيان انها تزف
الشهيد مهند شحاده من كتائب القسام وتبارك
عمليه اطلاق النار البطوليه جنوب نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه مؤكده ان العمليه رساله
واضحه لحكومه الاحتلال واوضحت ان العمليه
رد طبيعي على مجزره جنين امس وعلى مخططات
الاحتلال التي وصفتها بالخبيثه لتقسيم
المسجد الاقصى واستكمال حلقات تهويده
واضافت ان على حكومه الاحتلال ان تدرك ان
استمرارها في اجرامها بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
ومقدساته وفي القلب منها المسجد الاقصى
سيجعل من هذه العمليه مجرد بدايه لسلسله
من اعمال المقاومه
هذا وقالت مصادر امنيه اسرائيليه ان منفدي
العمليه كانا معا في نفس الزنزانه في سجن
مجدو الاسرائيلي عام 2020 نتعرف عن قرب
على منفذي العمليه
[موسيقى]
ووصف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو عمليه عيله بالاجراميه والمفزعه
واضاف ان الاجهزه الامنيه تعمل الان من
اجل محاسبه من وصفهم بالقتله وقال نتنياهو
ان من يسعى لايقاع الادب اسرائيل يواجهوا
اما بالقبر او السجن حسب وصفه
اليوم قرب مستوطنه عيلي وقعت عمليه
اجراميه مفزعه قواتنا تعمل الان في
الميدان من اجل محاسبه القتله لقد اثبتنا
في الشهور الاخيره اننا نقتص من كل القتله
دون اي استثناء كل من مسنا بسوء فهو الان
اما في القبر او السجن وهذا ما سيحصل في
هذه الحاله ايضا اريد ان اقول لمن يسعى
لايقاع الاذى بنا كل الخيارات مفتوحه
سنواصل العمل ضد الارهاب بكل قوه وسننتصر
عليه
من جانبها دع وزير الامن القوميه
الاسرائيليه اعتماد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الى شن عمليه عسكريه في الضفه الغربيه
والى العوده الى تنفيذ عمليات اغتيال كما
طالب بن كفاره عقب وصوله موقع العمليه
قربه مستوطنه عيله بالاسراع في تمرير
مشروع قانون عقوبه الاعدام على من سماهم
المخربين
سكان يهودا والسامره الى حمل السلاح فهذا
امر ينقذ الارواح الاحداث هنا تتواصل
اطلاق نار وراء اطلاق نار اقول لرئيس
الوزراء ولوزير الدفاع الذين اكنوا لهما
كل التقدير لقد حان الوقت لعمليه عسكريه
في يهودا والسامره نعم العوده الى
الاغتيالات من الجو وهدم المباني ونصب
الحواجز وطرد الارهابيين وتمرير مشروع
قانون انزال عقوبه الاعدام على المخربين
للاسف الحواجز ازيلت لتسهيل حريه الحركه
لكن ذلك ليس باهم من حقنا كمستوطنين في
الحياه
قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي انه لم
يكن لدى اجهزه الامن معلومات استخباريه
تفيد بتخطيط عنصرين من حماس لتنفيذ
العمليه هذا واقرر الرئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي
تعزيز انتشار القوات الاسرائيليه الشماليه
الضفه الغربيه جاء قرارها خلال زياره
تفاقديه لمكان العمليه حيث اوعز على اثرها
بشن عمليات اعتقال لفلسطينيين
وقد هاجم مستوطنون بلده حوار جنوبي نابلس
واحرق واراضي زراعيه واعتدوا على ممتلكات
الاهالي وقد تصدى عشره شبان الفلسطينيين
للمستوطنين فردت عليهم قوات الاحتلال
باطلاق الرصاص المعدني وقنابل الغاز وذلك
بهدف ابعادهم واخراج المستوطنين المهاجمين
قالت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها تطالب
بتدخل امريكي عاجل لمنع الانفجار الذي
يحضر له غلاه المتطرفين وارسلت البعثه
الفلسطينيه لدى الامم المتحده رساله لمجلس
الامن الدولي بشان العمليه الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في جنين قالت فيها ان اسرائيل
نفذت غارات جويه في هجوم على الضفه
الغربيه المحتله للمره الاولى منذ عام
2002 وعرضت المدنيين لخطر شديد واوضحت
البعثه ان اسرائيل استهدفت عمدا العاملين
في المجال الانساني ومنعت الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني من الوصول الى الضحايا واضافت
انه من الواضح ان غياب المساءله يشجع على
اجرام اسرائيل وعلى وحشيتها ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وادعت المجتمع الدولي الى
الاهتمام الفوري بالعدوان المفزع الذي
تشنه اسرائيل على الشعب الفلسطيني
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور هاني
المصري مدير مركز مسارات للابحاث
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه كما ينضم الينا من
الناصره جاكي خوري الباحث المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن ريتشارد
جوتسين المبعوث الخاص السابق للرئيس
بلكلينتون لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط ابدا معك
دكتور هاني دكتور هاني كيف تقرا هذه
العمليه من حيث التوقيت المكان والاسلحه
المستخدمه
اعتقد ان هذه العمليه نوعيه وجاءت رد سريع
يعني بعد مرور 24 ساعه على المجزره التي
ارتكبتها القوات الاسرائيليه في جنين
واستخدمت فيها يعني بنادق حديثا ام 16
وكانت جريئه وادت الى خسائر اسرائيليه
كبيره اربع قتله واربع جرحى هذا يدل على
ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه رغم كل عمليات
الاقتحام والاغتيال والاعتقال وتوسيع
الاستيطان والفصل العنصري والاعتداءات على
الاقصى والحصار الخانق لقطاع غزه كل هذه
العمليات لا تؤدي الى استسلام الفلسطينيين
كسر ارادتهم بل كما لاحظنا بالامس هناك
استحداث في استخدام الوسائل القتاليه
استخدمت عبوات ادت الى تعطيل يعني
دوريات اسرائيليه بشكل كبير مما ادى الى
عمليه
محاوله اسرائيليه معقده لسحب بقواتها
استغرقت ساعات كثيره وادت الى جرحى في
صفوف الاسرائيليين وهذا يعني ان المقاومه
ومجموعات المقاومه تستفيد من تجاربها
السابقه من حيث استخدام وسائل الاتصال
الحديثه لانها كانت يعني تسهل عمليه القاء
القبض عليهم او اغتيالهم من حيث وضع عبوات
وهذه من حيث المفاجاه هذا يدل على ان لكل
فعل رد فعل مساوي له في المقدار ومعاكس في
الاتجاه بالتالي حكومه الحسم الاسرائيليه
حكومه المتطرفين الفاشين لم تؤدي الى ردح
الفلسطينيين بل خسرت اسرائيل 22 قتيل منذ
بدايه هذا العام نفذت 120 عمليه متنوعه
اطلاق رصاص على مواقع اسرائيليه مختلفه
وهذا يدل على ان الشعب الفلسطيني لن يرفع
الرايه البيضاء ولا يمكن ان يستسلم
دعني اسمع من السيد جاك يا سيد جاكي كيف
سترد اسرائيل على هذه العمليه وما هي
المعطيات التي تاخذها بعين الاعتبار في اي
رد لها
يعني واضح ان هنالك فجوه في القراءه
بالبعد التنفيذي بالنسبه لحكومه نتنياهو
ممثله ببن جير وسمودريتش وكما استمعنا الى
بعض التصريحات ايضا في تقاريركم هنالك من
يدفع لها باتجاه عمليه عسكريه واسعه لربما
تحاكي ما كان قبل اكثر من عشرين عاما
عندما تمت عمليه اجتياح مجدده للضفه
الغربيه هذه المره يتحدثون عن شمال الضفه
الغربيه من نابلس شمالا وتحديدا في مدينه
جنين وفي محيطها بمعنى التواجد العسكري
الدائم وعلى مدار الساعه في المخيم في
المدينه في الازقه كذلك يعني قطع
الاحترافيه
وبشكل واضحا
هنالك من يدفع بهذا الاتجاه ولكن اعتقد ان
المستوى نعم ولكن المشكله الان بالنسبه
للمستوى العسكري وتحديدا ايضا يعني الجيش
وكذلك جهاز الامن العام هنالك التحفظ من
هذه الخطوات لسببين رئيسيين اولا نحن
نتحدث الان عن خلايا صغيره مجموعات من
الشباب المسلح هي لا تنضوي تحت الاطار
الهرمي التنظيمي لحركه حماسه والجاد
الاسلامي بمفهوم ان هنالك اوامر عليا تصدر
لهم وهم يذهبون الى عمليه التنفيذ اعتقد
ما كان هذه الليله هو الرهن ايضا
التحقيقات وبشكل عميق لدى المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه هل نتحدث هنا عن تغيير جوهري
بمعنى التحول مما يعرف بالذئاب المنفلته
التي تخرج متى تشاء وكيف ما تقرر الى
تنفيذ عمليه واطلاق نار ام ان هنالك اوامر
عليا بمعنى هنالك التنظيم الهرمي وهنالك
خلايا نائمه بدات تتحرك على الارض
بالاضافه الى المتغير الذي دخل على اللعبه
يوم امس من خلال
العبوات الناسفه بشكل رسميا لهذه العمليه
كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على الرد الاسرائيلي
كما ذكرت اذا ذهبنا الى المستوى السياسي
يريدون عمليه اجتياح انا ارجح الحل الثاني
الذي يقترح الان لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي من
خلال عمليات
دعيني اقول محدوده داخل المدن داخل
المخيمات محاوله الوصول بناء على
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه للشبان المسلحين
وليس من خلال عمليه اجتياح وتواجد دائم
داخل الشوارع وداخل الازقه والاحياء لانما
حدث في جنين بالامس وايضا مؤشر لما قد
يكون عندما يتواجد الجيش بشكل دائم على
مدار الساعه في الاحياء وفي المدن
الفلسطينيه امام عشرات الشبان المسلحين من
جهه وبتواجد ايضا لعبوات مسلحه انا لا
اعتقد انهم يريدون الذهاب الى هذا المسار
قضيه اخرى لا تقل اهميه حتى الان مثلا لم
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي والمؤسسه الامنيه
عن وقف دخول العمال الفلسطينيين وكذلك كل
ما يتعلق بعمليه المعابر وحركه المعابر
التجاريه لانهم يعرفون جيدا ان الذهاب الى
هذا المسار هو معناه المزيد من الضغط على
السكان على المدنيين على العمال وهذا لن
ياتي بنوع من الهدوء بل على العكس تماما
سيزيد فقط من نسبه الضغط لدى الجمهور
الفلسطيني لدى الشباب الفلسطيني وبالتالي
واضح ان هنالك حيره لدى المؤسسه الامنيه
والسياسيه تحديدا المؤسسه الامنيه
والاستخباراتيه هل نذهب الى التصعيد شامل
كما كان في العام الفين قبل 23 عام ام
نذهب في بعد المهاجمه المحدده بناء على
معلومات استخباراتيه انا اعتقد من اجل
ارضاء المستوطنين خلال الفتره القريبه
سنجد المزيد من الحواجز سنجد المزيد من
الاجراءات تابعنا ايضا البلاغ العسكري
الاسرائيلي عن تواجد مكثف للجيش في
الشوارع ولكن نحن نذهب الان ايضا الى
اجازه العيد خلال الفتره القريبه هل تريد
اسرائيل هذا التصعيد امام الفلسطيني بشكل
كامل في الضفه الغربيه الكثير من الاسئله
تطرح لا اعتقد ان هنالك اجابات واضحه كما
ذكرت حتى عندما استمع الى المراقبين
ولكن دعني اسمع من السيد ريتشارد سيد
ريتشارد الخارجيه الفلسطينيه بشكل واضح
تطالب بتدخل امريكي عاجل لمنع الانفجار
كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى الاداره الامريكيه مع
هذا الطلب وتتفاعل معه وهو ليس المره
الاولى على كل الاحوال
في الحقيقه
هذا التصعيد في اعمال العنف كان متوقعا
منذ 20 عاما كان الرد هو رمي الحجاره
والان يرمون كوكتيلات المولوتوف من قبل
كانوا يحرقون دواليب والان هناك عبوات
متفجره هذا التصعيد مره اخرى كان
متوقعان وهذا امر مؤسف ماذا يمكن الحكومه
الامريكيه والاداره الامريكيه ان تفعل
سيد ريتشارد عذرا على المقاطعه ولكن هنالك
توسيع على الاستيطان حتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ترفضه وتحذر منه رد الفعل
الفلسطينيه ياتي بعد سلسله من الاعمال
تقوم بها اسرائيل بحقهم
هناك عدد من النقاط المهمه احدى
المستوطنات كانت الولايات المتحده واضحه
بالنسبه الى موضوع تعزيز او توسيع
المستوطنات ان هذا امر غير مقبول لا نعرف
ما سيكون الرد الامريكي اعتقد انه سيتخطى
مجرد الكلام ولكنه سيجري خلف الكواليس
وليس علنا ربما لا نعلم قبل فتره نقطه
اخرى اذا قدمت اسرائيل الولايات المتحده
ادله دامخه بوجود مشبه بهم خلف هذه
العمليه ضد اسرائيل هل يفترض بالولايات
المتحده ان تمنع اسرائيل عن التحرك
اجراءات ضد اشخاص لاسرائيل ادله بانه من
ارتكبوا جرائم هذا سؤال لقد راينا ما حصل
حين حاولت اسرائيل فعل ذلك وهذا ادى الى
انفجار
مباشره تقريبا لا اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده ستتدخل اذا كان لاسرائيل ادله مش
مهم واعتقد انها قدمت هذه الادله لكنني
اعتقد ان التصعيد في اعمال العنف من شانه
ان يستريع انتباه الاوساط السياسيه في
واشنطن وهذا لا يعني ان الولايات المتحده
ستتدخل لوقف اسرائيل ولكن ربما لحمل
الاطراف
مره اخيره من اجل
التحاور حول حل النهائي
دكتور هاني التعويل على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي من قبل السلطه
هل ياتي في محله
اعتقد ان هناك مبالغه كبيره في المراهنه
على الموقف الامريكي لان ما يجري هو شيء
كبير للغايه بدون عمليه سور واقيه جديد
هناك 170 شهيد فلسطين منذ بدايه هذا العام
هل هذا عدد قليل هل هذا مسموح بالنسبه
للاداره الامريكيه الاداره الامريكيه لا
تريد تدهور شامل لا تريد حرب تستدعي اطراف
اخرى سواء فلسطينيه او حزب الله او ايران
ابقاء الوضع على ما هو عليه مقبول بالنسبه
للاداره الامريكيه رغم كل التوسع
الاستيطاني ورغم كل العدوان بكل اشكاله
بالتالي التعويل على الاداره الامريكيه مع
اهميه وضعها امام مسؤولياتها لا يجب ان
نعفيها او نعفي المجتمع الدولي
بالمسؤولياتها ولكن التعويل يضيع الاتجاه
ويضيع العمل بالاتجاه المناسب الاتجاه
المناسب هو توفير عوامل الصمود الوحده
الفلسطينيه
الى المحاكم الدوليه التوجه الى القوه
التي يمكن ان تتحرك للضغط على اسرائيل
ومسائله اسرائيل ومعاقبه اسرائيل وليس
الاعراب عن القلق
والحزن والمناشده والتمني هذه السياسه لا
تشمن ولا تغني من جوع هذا امر يعني مهم
بالتالي لا يجب ان نعتبر ما يجري وكانه
شيء عادي او مقبول ما يجري هو منزل يوميا
مستمره الدولي من مسؤولياته ولكن كيف يمكن
تحقيق ذلك والمجتمع الدولي في كل المرات
السابقه جل ما يقوم به هو التنديد هو
الدعوه لضبط النفس هو التوقف عند كلمات
تدعو الى ضبط النفس والحفاظ على الوضع
الراهن
اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي سيتحرك عندما يرى
ان الفلسطيني لن يسكت سيقوم ردود تتناسب
مع مستوى الخطر والتحديات والعدوان عندما
يشعر ان الامور يمكن ان تتدهور بشكل شامل
في هذه الحاله يمكن ان نشهد تحرك من
المجتمع الدولي ولكن اذا بقيت الامور على
ما هي عليه هناك تعايش من الاداره
الامريكيه ومن المجتمع الدولي مع هذا
الوضع اذا وجدوا ايضا ان القياده
الفلسطينيه لا تكتفي بالتهديدات
والمناشدات اللفظيه وانما تقوم بتطبيق
القرارات التي اتخذت منذ عام 2015 سواء
بالمجلس المركزي او المجلس الوطني بخصوص
اعاده النظر في العلاقه مع الاحتلال سواء
بالنسبه للتنسيق الامني التبعيه
الاقتصاديه الاعتراف باسرائيل هذه مسائل
عندما يشعر المجتمع الدولي عندما يشعر
الاداره الامريكيه ان السلطه والقياده
الفلسطينيه جاده ولا تكتفي بتهديدات لفظيه
بقرارات لا تنفذ عندها يمكن ان يتحرك ولكن
للاسف الردود الفلسطينيه نمطيه وهي تخشى
القياده من المواجهه رغم ان المواجهه
مفروضه على الفلسطينيين الفلسطينيين في
موقع الدفاع عن النفس وهذا حق لكل انسان
لكل شعب وخاصه شعب تحت الاحتلال وفي ظل
حكومه تقول انها اتت لحسم الصراع بسرعه
ومن خلال حرب طاحنه ضد الفلسطينيين هذا
يستدعي تحرك بمستوى هذا الخطر من القياده
الفلسطينيه من الشعب الفلسطيني من القوى
الفلسطينيه يكفي هذا الانقسام المدمر الذي
يستنزف طاقات الشعب الفلسطيني وخصوصا ان
ما تطرحه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا يلبي اي
حقوق او اي مصالح لاي طرف تستهدف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كل الفلسطينيين وتضع
الفلسطينيين امام ثلاثه خيارات اما الهجره
الطوعيه او القصريه ام اما الاستسلام
الكامل واما الجيش تتكفل بهم ان يقتلهم
هذا هو الخيار الذي تضعه هذه الحكومه اذا
لم يتم ردعها والردع يبدا من فلسطين ولكن
فلسطين لوحدها لا تستطيع ان تتحمل يعني
هذه الاعباء ولكن مسؤوليتها وواجبها ان
تدافع عن نفسها عن ارضها عن شعبها عن
حقوقها عن مصالحها وهذا ما يفعله الشعب
الفلسطيني كما نلاحظ يعني في السنوات
الاخيره بشكل فعال اكثر من الفترات
السابقه ولكن بدون وعاء سياسي بدون قياده
بدون برامج وهذا الامر لا يجعل النتائج
السياسيه من هذه المقاومه كما يجب وبما
يتناسب مع حجم التضحيات ما جرى في جنين
امس وتطور القدرات التي تمتلكها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هل يمكن ان تشكل رابعا
لاسرائيل او على الاقل تفكر مرتين قبل
الاقدام على رد على عمليه اليوم
يعني لا اعتقد انه في هذه المرحله يمكن ان
اتحدث عن تغيير جوهري في ميزان الردع خاصه
وانما حصل بالامس ونعم ادى الى اصابات في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي والى يعني تعطيل
عدد من الاليات ولكن لا نتحدث الان عن
تغيير جوهري ونوعي امام القوه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وبالنسبه لاسرائيل هنالك الان
تحدي في البعد العسكري في ثلاثه مسارات
الاول هل هنالك فعلا تطور في هذه العبوات
الناسفه التي تنتج محليا وهل هنالك خبرات
خارجيه تصدر الى داخل الضفه الغربيه
وبالتالي بدات تترجم بالبعد العمليات
العسكري ثانيا هل يمكن ان تتطور هذه
العبوات الى تطوير اسلحه اخرى خاصه ما حصل
في قطاع غزه من ناحيه ذخيره ومن ناحيه
اطلاق قذائف باتجاه المدن الايطاليه
ونتحدث هنا عن مسافات قريبه جدا يمكن ان
تعطل حتى قلب يعني اسرائيل وبالتالي واضح
انه هذا تحدي هذه الامور يتم فحص بناء على
معلوماتي لم يصلوا الى هذه المرحله ما
زالت المؤسسه العسكريه تتعامل مع المشهد
الفلسطيني بالبعد العسكري داخل الاحياء
داخل الازقه داخل المدن وليس بمفهوم انها
بدات تقترب من التجمعات السكانيه داخل
الخط الاخضر وبالتالي تبقى القضيه
الاساسيه الان المتعلقه بامن المستوطنين
وهو ما حصل اليوم في الهجوم على المطعم في
محيط احدى المستوطنات بمعنى الضغط لا من
قبل المستوطنين نحن نريد الامن والسلام
كما انتم تؤمنون هذا الامن والسلام بقوسين
طبعا داخل اسرائيل وعليه الدفع باتجاه
تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه واسعه هذا لن يحدث
ولكن كما ذكرت في الاجابه الاولى قد نجد
الان المزيد من الحواجز المزيد من
الاجراءات التي ستزيد الضغط على المواطنين
الفلسطيني وبالتالي يؤدي هذا الى تصعيد
الاوضاع فعليه هنالك طبعا سيكون تفاوت
كبير في قراءه المشهد واعتقد ان نتنياهو
كما هو نتنياه سيذهب في مرحله المماطله
والتاجيل حتى لا تصل الامور الى تصعيد
اكبر واكبر تلزمه بالدفع نحو عمليه عسكريه
واسعه خلال الفتره ايضا المرحله حجم
التوافق بين المستويين السياسيه والعسكري
كيف يمكن وصفه
على طبيعه الرد بالطبع انا لا اعتقد ان
هنالك توافق بمفهوم نعم يعني لا اعتقد ان
هنالك توافق في هذه المرحله هنالك ضغوط
تمارس علينا كما ذكرت من اقطاب ائتلافه
وخاصه نتحدث عن ائتلاف بصلبه هم من
المستوطنين اذا كانت
مجلس المستوطنات ولكن اعتقد ان حسابات
نتنيه وقد تكون مختلفه بعض شيء هو يدرك
جيدا ايضا ان عمليه عسكريه واسعه قد تؤدي
الى تعطيل بعض الامور المتعلقه بالمسار
الذي يذهب اليه في المشاريع الاقتصاديه في
بعض الامور التي بدات تقد مضاجع المواطنه
الاسرائيلي مثل غلاء المعيشه ولكن نعم قد
تكون له فرصه على الاقل مرحليه في ان يصدر
الازمه الداخليه الى عمليه عسكريه واسعه
هذا قد يدفع الى تاجيل ما يرتبط
بالاصلاحات القضائيه التي يتحدث عنها
والتي تعرفها المعارضه بانها بالسيطره على
جهاز القضاء الذهاب الى تمرير الوقت حتى
نهايه شهر الشهر والذهاب بعد ذلك الى فتره
الاجازات ولكن هل يستطيع ان تنيع ان يراهن
على هذا الامر خلال الفتره القريبه طبعا
هذه مراهنه كبيره طبعا انا اوافق ما قال
الاستاذ هاني بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
بانه لا يمكن التعويل على ادارتهم للازمه
من حين الى اخر ولكن هنالك متغير انا لا
يعني اتجاهل بشكل كامل هل الزياره التي
كانت في الاسبوع الماضي الى دوله ضخمه مثل
الصين يمكن ان تبدا الان بعض البوادر
الاولى في تحركها على المسرح الدولي ايضا
امام الدول العربيه ان يؤدي الى تغيير في
بعض الموازين موازين وموازين القوى في هذه
المرحله طبعا هذه مراهنه غير واضحه الان
ولكن اعتقد هنالك متغيرات على مستوى الشرق
الاوسط لا نستطيع ان نتجاهلها تماما قضيه
مهمه ايضا هل العالم الان رغم انشغال
المجتمع الدولي فيما يحدث في اوكرانيا
وروسيا يريد الان ايضا نوع من الصخب على
مسرح الاحداث في الشرق الاوسط هذه ايضا
علامه لابد ان اتوقف عندها من السيد
ريتشارد سيد ريتشرد يعني هل من مصلحه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وان كانت حسب
ما تقول السلطه الفلسطينيه انها لا تسائل
اسرائيل وهذا ما يشجعها على القيام بما
تقوم به هل من مصلحه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي في هذا التوقيت
انفجار على مستوى كبير في الشرق الاوسط في
المنطقه
طبعا لا طبعا لا اعتقد ان القضيه التي لم
تناقش الان
هي شيء يعدنا بما هو ايجابي نوعا ما وهو
ما تحاول الولايات المتحده ان تقوم به
بالنسبه الى علاقتها مع السعوديه وعلاقه
اسرائيل بالسعوديه
يبدو ان هناك جهود في محاوله لتلطيف هذه
العلاقات
حتى تصير السعوديه جزءا من اتفاقات عبرها
بشرط كما ورد في التقارير وهو ان نتنياهو
يجب ان يتراجع بعض الشيء فيما يتعلق
بالمستوطنات
واتخاذ خطوات باتجاه اتفاق
السعوديه نفذ ذلك فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الامريكي الموقف الامريكي كان واضحا
وحاسما فيما يتعلق بتعديل القوانين في
اسرائيل لماذا لا نرى موقفا مشابها فيما
يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه على الرغم من
ادانه توسيع المستوطنات على الرغم من كل
ما تقوم به هذه الحكومه منذ وصولها
مجددا
منذ ان استلم بعيدا الرئاسه كان واضحا
وضوح الشمس ان توسيع المستوطنات غير مرحب
به
وانا سمعت تقارير بان اسرائيل غير راضيه
خلف الكواليس
عما لا تحصل عليه من دعم من الحكومه
الامريكيه من حيث التشارك المعلومات
الاستخباريه ومواضيع اخرى ايضا انا لا
افترض ان الاداره الامريكيه لا تحرك ساكنا
مع توسيع المستوطنات انا لا اعتقد ان
اتهامها بذلك صحيح بالنسبه الى البعض فهم
يعتبرون ان الفلسطينيين يقدمون مكافات او
دعم
لاسرمان تعتبرهم اسرائيل ارهابيين لا اعرف
اذا كان هذا صحيحا ام لا ولكن طالما هناك
اعتقاد بان هذا صحيح الفلسطينيون لم ينفوا
ذلك كذلك فكره ان اسرائيل سوف تنسحب تماما
من الضفه الغربيه ليست منطقيه اعتقد ان
المواطنين الفلسطينيين يجب ان يخدعوا بذلك
لدينا مثال في غزه حين انسحبت اسرائيل
وتلقت الالاف من الصواريخ
لدي اقل من دقيقه اسمع تعليق من الدكتور
هاني على ما ذكرت تفضل دكتور هاني
انا اعتقد ان هناك مغالطات كبيره فيما
تفضل به
ريتشارد اسرائيل دوله محتله وليست دوله
طبيعيه وهو بسبب هذا الاحتلال يترتب عليه
كل اشكال العدوان وكل اشكال العنصريه وهذا
الذي دفع اسرائيل الان الى الاتجاه نحو
الفاشيه اذا تجاهلنا ان اسرائيل دوله
محتله نقول عن المقاومه ارهاب المقاومه حق
مشروع للاحتلال هذا الحق يقر القانون
الدولي وكل الاديان وكل المواثيق الدينيه
والدنيويه وبالتالي ماذا يفعل الفلسطيني
لا يوجد اي عمليه سياسيه لا يوجد اي افق
سياسي لا يوجد اي ضغط دولي على اسرائيل
وانما يوجد عمليات قتل يومي واعتقال يومي
وهدم منازل وتطير عنصري ويطالب الفلسطيني
بان يسكت كيف يمكن هذا هل لو تعرضت
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لجزء مما
يتعرض له الشعب الفلسطيني يقبل ريتشارد
بما يحدث اعتقد ان الجواب معروف تماما
شكرا لك دكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات للابحاث والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والشكر موصول للسيد جاكي خوري الباحث
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه وايضا السيد
ريتشارد غوتستين المبعوث الخاص السابق
للرئيس بيل كلينتن لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وهذه هي الصور تاتينا مباشره من نابلس
لتشييع جثمان الشهيد خالد صباح اذا هذه
الصور تاتينا مباشره من نابلس
لعمليه تشييع تجريع لخالد صباح وهو احد
منفذي عمليه ايله التي شهدناها بعد ظهر
هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
يا خالد يا مهند
نشاهد هذه الصور من نابلس لعمليه التشييع
التي تجري الان وهي لاحد منفذي عمليه عيله
وكانت هذه العمليه قد ادت الى مقتل اربعه
مستوطنين اسرائيليين واطلقت اطلق الجانب
الاسرائيلي النار على منفذي العمليه
والداهما قتلى حركه حماس اعلنت مسؤوليتها
عن عمليه مستوطنه عيديه وقالت ان منفذيها
من منتسبي كتائب القسام وقالت ايضا ان
العمليه رساله واضحه لحكومه الاحتلال
هذا وقام الجانب الاسرائيلي بمشاورات
امنيه برئاسه نتنياهو الذي قال رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه قال ان كل الخيارات
متاحه في هذه المرحله بنكفير وزير الامن
القومي كان قد زار مكان العمليه ودعا من
هناك الى عمليه واسعه تشمل اغتيالات في
الضفه الغربيه
نشاهد هذه الصور لعمليه التشييع وهذه
الصور تاتينا مباشره من نابلس
السلطه الوطنيه بدورها دعت المجتمع الدولي
للتدخل وحتى الجانب الامريكي على التدخل
من اجل وقف ما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وكان مستوطنون قد هاجموا بلده حواره جنوبي
نابلس واحرق واراضي زراعيه واعتدوا على
ممتلكات الاهالي هناك
[موسيقى]
اذا نحن نشاهد تشييع جثمان خالد صباح احد
منفدي عمليه مستوطنه عيني هذه العمليه
التي جرت بعد ظهور اليوم وادت الى مقتل
عدد من المستوطنين الاسرائيليين وعلى
اثرها قامت الحكومه الاسرائيليه برئاسه
نتنياهو بمشاورات امنيه قال قبل هذه
المشاورات ان كل الخيارات متاحه ويقوم
الجانب
الاسرائيلي المتطرف بالدعوه الى عمليه
واسعه تشمل اغتيالات هذا ما جاء على لسان
وزير الامن القومي بنكفير وعاقب هذه
العمليه قام مستوطنون بمهاجمه بلده حواره
جنوبيه نابلس واحرق واراضي زراعيه وقد
تصدى عشرات الشبان الفلسطينيين للمستوطنين
فردت عليهم قوات الاح باطلاق الرصاص
المعدني وقنابل الغاز بهدف ابعادهم واخراج
المستوطنين المهاجمين تولى ردود الفعل على
هذه العمليه حركه حماس تبنت هذه العمليه
وقالت ان منفذي هذه العمليه ينتميان الى
كتائب القسامه اما السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه فقد دعت المجتمع الدولي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالتحديد
لتدخل عاجل لمنع ما وصفته بالانفجار الذي
يحضر له غلاه المتطرفين بحسب الخارجيات
الفلسطينيه وفي الوقت عينه ارسلت البعثه
الفلسطينيه لدى الامم المتحده رساله لمجلس
الامن الدولي بشان العمليه الاسرائيليه
الاخيره في جنين
وكما ذكرنا دعوه وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اعتمار بنكفير رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي الى عدم الاكتفاء بالاجراءات
التاديبيه وفصل الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين
ظهروا في مقطع فيديو يهتفون لجنين ويشتمون
اسرائيل وكانت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه قالت
ان جنودا بالجيش الاسرائيلي صوروا تسجيلا
لانفسهم على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وهم
يشتمون اسرائيل ويهنئون من سمتهم هيئه
البث بالارهابيين في جنينه ووصف المتحدث
باسم الجيش السلوك بالمخالف لما سماه قيم
الجيش الاسرائيلي قائلا انه سيتم التعامل
معهم بطريقه تاديبيه
[موسيقى]
والان الى التطورات في السودان فمع اقتراب
هدنه الايام الثلاثه من نهايتها شهدت
مناطق في الخرطوم اشتباكات بالاسلحه
الخفيفه كما استمر الاقتتال القبلي في
مناطق باقليم دارفور وتوسعت رقعته مع سقوط
مزيدا من الضحايا هذا وقال مصدر سوداني
مطلع للجزيره قبل قليل ان الجيش والدعم
السريع يبحثان في جده هدنه جديده مطوله
ذات علاقه بعيد الاضحى في غضون ذلك رفضت
الحكومه السودانيه بيانا وزراء خارجيه
الاليه الرباعيه للايجاد واعتبرته انتهاكا
لسياده البلاد كما جددت اعتراضها على
استضافه كينيا للعمليه السياسيه لحل
الصراع السوداني
عشيه انتهاء هدنه اخرى لم تهدا فيها
للنفوس ولا الاسلحه اشتباكات متقطعه في
مناطق متفرقه من الخرطوم بالاسلحه الخفيفه
لكنها تثقل فاتوره الصراع الذي يغرق
السودان في الموت والدمار بسرعه غير
مسبوقه الوصف للامين العام للامم المتحده
تنتهي الهدنه الانسانيه المعلنه التي شهدت
كالعاده خروقات الاربعاء الساعه السادسه
صباحا القتال الاعنف يدور حاليا في دارفور
والقتل على الهويه القبليه يتسع بشكل مرعب
يدفع بعشرات الالاف الى الهرب للجاره تشاد
احيانا مشيا على الاقدام استنادا لمصادر
محليه وقع اقتتال بين قبيلتي الهبانيه
والسلامات في اللطيف جنوبي مدينه نيالا
بولايه جنوب دارفور حديث عن سقوط القتلى
وشرح ولا خبر عن قرب وقف المواجهات
المسلحه بين المتنحرين يحذر حاكم اقليم
دارفور من السيناريو الاسوا وهو نشوب حرب
اهليه مثل تلك التي عصفت برواندا وتركت
ندوبا الى يومنا هذا تم اقتيال عدد من
الادارات الاهليه والقيادات المجتمعيه
فهذا النوع من الاسلوب
ربما يقود المجتمع الى
انزلاق في الحرب الاهليه والحروب
الاجتماعيه التي ربما تشبه رواندا
مناخ السودان هذه الشهور لا يتحمل
الدبلوماسيه على ما يبدو وبالاخص مبادره
الايجاد ومن عرض لحل سلمي للنزاع الى ازمه
مع الجيش السوداني بيان وزراء الخارجيه في
الاليه الرباعيه لم يلقى الترحيب قال مصدر
في الحكومه ان البيان غير مقبولا ويمثل
تحديا واضحا للسودان وانتهاكا لسيادته
مضيفا ان استضافه كينيا للعمليات السياسيه
تعني سيطره مجموعات من خارج القاره
الافريقيه على جهود تسويه الازمه كان بيان
سابق للخارجيه السودانيه رفض نقل رئاسه
اللجنه من جنوب السودان الى دوله كينيا
التي وصفها بالطرف غير المحايد في الصراع
وتضم الرباعيه كينيا وجيبوتي وجنوب
السودان واثيوبيا ابرز ما جاء في بيان
وزراء الخارجيه الاتفاق على اعتماد نهج
تدريجي لحل النزاع في السودان واعطاء
الاولويه الى عقد لقاءات مباشره الطرفي
الصراع لمناقشه القضايا الرئيسيه الاتفاق
ايضا على التنسيق والتعاون الوثيق مع
الاحزاب السودانيه والجهات المعنيه وضمان
قياده سودانيه لعمليه السلام تبقى ابواب
الحوار الجدي والسلمي بين الاخوه الاعداء
مرتضى بلا افق واضح متى ستفتح او على
الاقل تكون مواربه يترجى رئيس المفوضيه
الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين دول الجوار
السوداني لابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الفارين من جحيم الصراع الى دول هشه لديها
مخاوفها وهواجسها وازمتها من الخرطوم الى
دارفور شهور الوجع السوداني تطول وتنهش
جسد الامه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الاكاديميه
السودانيه المختص في الشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه الدكتور اسامه عيدروس دكتور
اسامه ايضا مصادر سودانيه تقول للجزيره ان
الجيش والدعم السريع يجريان مباحثات في
جده لهدنه مطوله تتعلق بعيد الاضحى ما
المقصود بمطوله بدايه وبتقديرك هل سينجح
الجانبان في هدنه جديده كما في السابق
الحنه الحاليه والتي تبقى عليها ساعات حتى
تنتهي نعم هي 72 ساعه فعندما نتحدث عن
هدنه مطوله ربما نعود مره ثانيه لهدنه
الاسبوع في القتال وهذه هذه مفاوضات جده
يعني تعمل بهذا الريزيم يعني تبدا بيوم
لكسر حده العنف ثم
تمدد لهدنه اطول قليلا ثم تبني على هذا
لهن
الان هذا الذي يتساءل عنه الشارع السوداني
حقيقه يعني هذه الهدى المجرد اعلان عام
صحيح تتوقف فيه المعارك
الصعبه والقويه
وحده المدافع والرصاص والطيران وكذا وتخفض
لكن على الارض كل ما تاتي هدنه تزيد
معاناه المواطنين بشكل كبير يعني الحقيقه
هي السؤال عن الميسرين لماذا لا يضعوا
يعني معيار لهذه الهدل يعني الان الوضع
مروع جدا في الجنينه ما الذي سيستفيده
مواطنا الجنينه من هذه الهدنه لماذا لا
تكون هنالك خطوات عمليه تؤكد نسمع حديثه
عن اليات لمراقبه من يقوم بالخروقات ولكن
الى حد الان لم نلمس اي تحرك جدي فيما
يتعلق بالاليات ما الذي يمنع وضع اليات
واضحه لمراقبه الخروقات هو قبل قبل
الاليات للمراقبه طبعا السودان دوله واسعه
وكبيره جدا لكن قبل المراقبه نفسها يعني
على ماذا تتم الهدنه فقط حديث عن انسانيه
لادخال المساعدات المساعدات الانسانيه
بتدخل لا في مرافق صحيه يتم اخلائها لافي
بل بالعكس يتوسع يعني الدعم السريع فاقد
السيطره على قواده بحيث انه لا يمكن ان
يلزمهم باي شيء لا يمكن ان يلزمهم بوقف
القتال في الجنينه
ويعزو الامر الى دخول ميليشيات من غير
قواته ولذلك هو لا يستطيع ان
قواته تهاجم المواطنين في الطويله وترتكب
جرائم في طويله في دارفور قواته تهجر
المواطنين قسريا من بيوتهم في الخرطوم
المواطن نفسه يعاني السؤال انه ما الذي
يستفيده
هذه الامور وتحددها ترك امر الحرب للجيش
والدعم السريع يعني يدير المعركه على
الارض تحصل الانتهاكات على الارض من قبل
الدعم السريع اقترحت في خطتها ان يتم
توسيع المناقشات لتشمل احزاب سودانيه
وجهات معنيه وضمان قياده سودانيه لعمليه
السلام الا ان الجانب السوداني الجيش
السوداني رفض مبادره الايجاب هذا النفس
طرح من الخارج يعني عندما تتحدث عن قياده
سودانيه نحن نتحدث عن مبادره سودانيه من
قيادات مدنيه سياسيه سودانيه تتقدم لتدير
هذه الاسئله اي من الجانبين في هذا
التوقيت هو الان الازمه بلغت مبلغ صعب جدا
الانسان المدني في السودان يعاني يعني
نزيف الدم والانتهاكات تقع على المواطنين
المدنيين يجب ان يتقدم احد لحمايه هؤلاء
المدنيين من داخل السودان من داخل القوى
السياسيه السودانيه دكتور اسامه عيدروس
الاكاديمي السوداني المختص في الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه كنت معنا هنا في
الاستوديو
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تحتدم
المعارك شرقا وجنوبا وينبه وزير الدفاع
الروسي الى ان قوته تتصدى لما قال انها
هجمات قوات نخبه اوكرانيه دربها الناتو
فيزا
ويحذر مما غبه استهداف عمق الاراضي
الروسيه بصواريخ هي مارس ورم شادو تصريحات
تتزامن مع تجديد امريكي على ان شبه جزيره
القرم ارض اوكرانيه وانها تدعم جهود
استعادتها
[موسيقى]
يتدحرج الوضع المستعر على الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه لاوكرانيا بشكل لافت نحو تصعيد
اكبر في ظل تصريحات روسيه اوكرانيه
متلاحقه بدورها وزير الدفاع الروسي تحدث
عن القوه الاوكرانيه
منذ الرابع من الشهر الجاري في محاور
جنوبولوجيا واشار الى خطه اوكرانيه لضرب
شبه جزيره القرم بصواريخ غربيه
ووفقا لمعلوماتنا فان القياده الاوكرانيه
تخطط لضرب الاراضي الروسيه بما فيها شبه
جزيره القرن بصواريخ هاي مارس وستور شادو
استخدام هذه الصواريخ خارجه منطقه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه يعني المشاركه الكامله
للولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في الصراع
تصنف منظومه هاي مارس الامريكيه على انها
وحده سلاح متنقله يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ عده
في وقت متزامن وتحمل الصواريخ هايمارس على
راجمه تحمل كل واحده منها سته صواريخ
دقيقه التوجيه بمدى يبلغ نحو 70 كيلومترا
اما صواريخ ظل العاصفه البريطانيه فيبلغ
مداها اكثر من 155 ميلا اي ثلاثه اضعاف
مدى الصواريخ التي استخدمتها اوكرانيا حتى
الان وعلى خط تزويد كييف بالاسلحه اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان نظام
الدفاع الجوي متوسط المدى الفرنسيه
الايطالي سامبتي جرى توريده الى اوكرانيا
ويستخدم الصاروخ استر 30 للدفاع الجوي
البالستي ويتمتع بمدى يتراوح بين ثلاثه
ومئه وعشرين كيلومترا تتغير معطيات الحرب
ويتغير بنك الاهداف مع تزود كياف باسلحه
جديده ففيما الماضي استهدف صاروخ شادو
مقرا عسكريا روسيا في ميناء مدينه على بعد
70 ميلا تقريبا من مواقع الخطوط الاماميه
الاوكرانيه وتواجه احدى عشره منطقه داخل
مقاطعه الروسيه الحدوديه ضربات بشكل مستمر
وتشهد هذه المناطق توغلات اوكرانيه متكرره
وفق موسكو كما تبقى روستوف الحدوديه
جنوبيه روسيا ايضا مسرحا لهجمات صاروخيه
او بطائره مسيره مع تصدي الدفاعات الجويه
لها وعلى الحدود وضعت سلطات مقاطعه كورس
كالروسيه كل سيناريوهات لاجلاء سكان القرى
والبلدات الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا بسبب
مواصفاتها بالمخاطر المحتمله لمجموعات
تخريب اوكرانيه مدير جهاز الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه قال ان الجيش الروسي يصد
هجوما مضادا لتجمع قوات النيتو وليس هجوما
اوكرانيا بينما قال الامين العام للنيتو
ان الحلف ليس طرفا في الصراع في اوكرانيا
ارد الروسي لا يتاخر بدوره فوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت قبل ايام تدمير راجمه
هايبرس امريكيه بصاروخ موجه براجمه
الصواريخ الروسيه تورنادو اس وهي قادره
على ضرب العدو بدقه على مسافات تصل الى
120 كم
يتواصل توافد الحجاج السودانيين الى مدينه
سواكن في ولايه البحر الاحمر للسفر بحرا
لاداء فريضه الحج ويواجه الحجاج معاناه
شديده جراء انتقالهم برا من ولايات البلاد
الى ميناء سواكن بسبب ظروف الحرب ويبلغ
عدد حجاج السودان هذا العام نحو 17 الف
حاج وهو عدد يقل عن الحصه الممنوحه للبلاد
والمقدرة باربعه وثلاثين الف حاج بحسب
المجلس الاعلى السوداني للحج والعمره
الى مدينه سواكن في ولايه البحر الاحمر
يصل الحجاج السودانيون تباعا من عده
ولايات
بصعوبه تجاوز المخاطر الامنيه في مناطقهم
تاركين اهاليهم ولا يعرفون اي مصير قد
ينتظرهم في ظل استمرار الحرب
اختلط لديهم مشاعر الارتياح بالوصول الامن
الى المدينه بالحزن على ظروف بلادهم وتبدل
احوالها ان احنا تحركنا الرحله من جنوب
كردفان المنطقه الشرقيه قال حد ما وصلنا
الى المدينه سواء اخذت اربعه ايام
والله تعبانين والله محجين ومرقين الناس
هناك ودونا بالدموع والله وبعدين هنركبنا
والله شفت انا شفت دهون
هذه العجوز وباعت كل ما تملك لتحج هذا
العام
واستكملت كل الاجراءات القانونيه المطلوبه
وفجاه حدث ما لم يكن بالحسبان احترق
الجواز سفرها خلال قصف في الخرطوم طال
منزل عائلتها واليوم تنتظر في مدينه سواكن
تسهيل سفرها بنسخه مصوره من جوازها في
ظروف تفوق قدرتها على الاهتمام
انه يبكي الليله
ناكل كله كله
اعتاد اغلب الحجاج في السودان السفر جوا
كل عام لاداء فريضه الحج لكن اغلاق المجال
الجوي بسبب الحرب اجبرهم هذا العام على
السفر بالبحر ما شكل معاناه كبيره لهم قد
يكابدونها ايضا خلال رحله العوده
ليلا تبدا ترتيبات تفويج الحجاج عبر ميناء
سواكن
المنفذ البحري الوحيد لسفرهم الى ميناء
جده حيث يتم تحديد عدد المسافرين وفق سعه
السفينه الناقله
وبينما ينتظر الحجاج استكمال الاجراءات لا
تغادرهم المخاوف حتى وهم في صاله المغادره
والله طريقه اتصال معكم
يصل الحجاج الى محطتهم الاخيره لبدء رحله
بحريه تستغرق نحو عشر ساعات
يغادرون وهم يدركون ان معاناه اخرى في
انتظارهم
قرابه 17 الف حاج من السودان هذا العام مع
ان الحصه الممنوحه للبلاد تصل الى اكثر من
30 الف حاج
وتلك مفارقه تعكس ما بلغته الحرب من تاثير
حمدي البكاري الجزيره من ميناء سواكن في
ولايه البحر الاحمر بالسودان
نهايه الحصاد لهذه الليله الى